[Music]
maleficents you're one of the most
terrifying Disney villains of all time
but despite the tears you've been
leashed we can't help but feel sorry for
you we mean you're still a lizard for
crying out loud
all you wanted was for your daughter mal
to bring down the barrier but things got
a little mixed up along the way but we
thought you should know that she
succeeded too bad the victory is more
than a little bittersweet
we hope you don't take advantage to the
royal wedding because we all know what
happens when your invite gets lost in
the mail the United States of auradon
and the Isle of the Lost have more
connections than you may think
watch until the end to find out who the
parents of your favorite ak's and b ches
are you won't believe how many Disney
heroes now is related to know I don't
hate my dizzy Jermaine this Wheaton
talented dizzy Jermaine is one of the
most popular BK's for obvious reasons a
micro family dizzy is kind-hearted and
ready to fight for what's right dizzy is
the daughter of Zhu Zhu litter main
however her mother doesn't make an
appearance in the dissonance movies
instead dizzy is shown to have been
predominantly raised by her grandmother
Lady Tremaine a popular theory states
that Hans from Disney's frozen is
Dizzy's father and hey if the shoe fits
but while we're on the topic of shoes
let's take a look at Dizzy's extended
family Dizzy's stefaned is none other
than Cinderella making Chad charming and
dizzy first cousins through marriage
Dizzy's closest relatives are her six
sisters her aunt Anastasia and her
cousin Anthony Germaine King Benjamin
without King's been the people of the
Isle would still be in prison today his
big heart and Ford views change the
kingdom of Aragon for the better
Finn is the only son of power
hubbub Easton Bell but despite being
raised under the roof and rules Finn
develops life-changing opinions of his
own it's time for a new beginning when
Sven and Mao get married Ben will be the
son-in-law of the wicked Maleficent and
Hades but Ben's family tree is connected
to a handful of other Disney characters
there's a theory that princess Jane from
Tarzan is the descendant of Belle both
princesses bear striking resemblance and
wear the same color dress
and since Tarzan is said to be Elsa and
Anna's long-lost brother Ben may be
loosely related to the Queen and
princess of arendelle
Huma Huma is the villain turned hero who
stole our hearts and descendants three
she's the only daughter of Ursula the
sea witch and she's super proud of her
heritage umas father isn't in the
picture but tons of fans are certain
that dr. facile ear is her long-lost dad
this would make celia and uma half
sisters which would explain their
special bond in descendents three when
you think about it Ursula and dr. fossil
here would make an awesome couple they
both used dark magics persuasion and
song to con their victims into signing
binding contracts that always come with
a hefty price keep watching to find out
how Emma and Mal's family trees could be
connected
Celia facile ear so you facile ear was
first introduced in descendents three
she's the daughter of dr. facile ear and
is known for being a total daddy's girl
you make sure you get your cut although
she isn't mentioned in the movies Celia
has an older sister named Freddy facile
ear who appears in the animated short
series descendants wicked world if our
assumptions are right Celia and Freddy
are Emma's half sisters oddly enough
China and McClain who plays uma used to
voice Freddy's character in wicked world
however once Chyna was cast as uma her
role as Freddy was passed down to her
real-life sister Lauren McLain now why
would the Disney Channel do this if
there weren't any family trees between
uma and the facile ears
Carlos Deville the adorable Carlos de
Vil was born and raised on the Isle of
the Lost
but his mother Cruella De Vil raised him
to be more of a servant than anything to
control him Cruella convince Carlos that
dogs were ferocious beasts who could not
be trusted
in reality it was karela who was the
most rabid one of all Carlos may be an
only child but he has a first cousin
named Diego and an uncle named - Sylvie
deville
Diego appears in novels like the Isle of
the lost and returned to the Isle of the
Lost but didn't make it into the Disney
Channel movies once Carlos marries Jane
he'll be the son-in-law of the wonderful
fairy godmother Jane Jane is an Aerodyne
kid who knows that love will conquer all
she fell for Carlos Deville in
descendants - and hasn't looked back
since
would you be my date for cotillion Jane
is the only daughter of the enchanting
fairy godmother she was raised to always
do the right thing which is what
attracted Carlos to Jane in the first
place
Jane is super close to tad charming for
more reasons than one first of all fairy
godmother and Cinderella's
see each other as family which is why we
aren't surprised that Chad and Jane have
a cousin vibe going on between them once
Jane and Carlos tie the knot she'll be
the very terrified daughter-in-law of
karela two Vil Perry hook there's no one
quite like Harry hook the only son of
Captain Hook from Disney's Peter Pan
Harry aspires to be like his father
going as far as holding the fake hook to
give up the same vibe Harry may appear
to be an only child in The Descendants
movies but The Descendants novels and
animated TV series beg to differ
Harry has an older sister named Harriet
hood and a younger sister named CJ hook
CJ is pictured to have blond hair in
descendants wicked world which makes us
wonder who Harry's real mother could be
the only blond-haired Disney villain out
there is Helga Sinclair from Atlantis
the lost Empire and if you need more
proof than that
how does last name ties Harry to his
Scottish heritage after all the name
Sinclair and derives from a reputable
Scottish clan eevee eevee is the only
daughter of the Evil Queen from Disney's
Snow White she was raised to be vain
calculating and sophisticated but
managed to lead with her heart instead
we could try to be friends put our
history behind us and celebrate our
differences at the moment no one knows
who Evie's real father is but many fans
believe that Haiti
is both mal and Evie's father this would
make mal and Evie half sisters however
there isn't enough proof to support this
theory which is why eby's father remains
a mystery but since queen grimhilde was
married to snow white father
this would make Evie and Snow White
stepsisters but unlike the Evil Queen
Evie isn't jealous of her stepsisters
good looks because Evie is the fairest
of them all
jay-j is the only member of the corps
for to know who his father is instead of
his mother
jay-z only son of Jafar from Disney's
Aladdin
but his family tree doesn't end there a
Disney inspired video game called
nasira's revenge- far has a fraternal
twin sister named nasira who also wound
up on the Isle of the Lost
and Jays antisera has a daughter named
Jade who is close today's age although
she doesn't appear in The Descendants
movies she was mentioned in the Isle of
the Lost book so despite not knowing who
his mother is Jay still has close female
relatives Lonnie Lonnie is a Nardin kid
who loves to test boundaries she's the
daughter of fallen and li Shang and she
means business just like her mother
Maya desires to break the mold and show
the world that girls can do anything
boys can do Lonnie is lucky enough to
have two supportive parents and the
family home in Northern Wei her great
grandmother is Brahma Fah and her
grandparents are Fozzie and folly out of
all the AKS in BK's Lonnie's family
appears to be the most normal Gill's if
you need a friend
gil is always there to lend a helping
hand gil is a simple VK who loves
adventure and learning new things he's
the son of Gaston from Disney's Beauty
and the Beast but he's nothing like his
father Gaston had three children Gaston
Jr Gaston the third and Gil the Gaston
sons have never mentioned who their
mother is
in this case we think it's much better
to ask who their mothers are the
bimbettes from Beauty and the beasts
were head-over-heels for Gaston and
since there's three of them it's
possible that Gaston had a son with each
of them Claudette Flores and Paulette
weren't the sharpest tools in the shed
which could be why Gil isn't always
quick to get the joke princess Audrey
unlike many other Disney Princesses
Audrey is royal on both sides of the
family
her mother Princess Aurora is the
daughter of King Stefan and Queen Leia
where it's her father Prince Phillip is
the son of King Hubert and his unnamed
wife Audrey's parents didn't play huge
roles in The Descendants movies but her
grandmother Queen Leia sure did
despite being born into a loving
household Audrey turned out to be a brat
but by the end of the sentence three she
really came full circle
Audrey also has a cousin named Ariana
rose he was introduced in the escape
from the Isle of the Lost
a descendents novel despite being
cousins Audrey and Ariana Rose don't
really get along chat Charming's chat
charming is the son of Cinderella and
Prince Charming
but his status just isn't good enough
for Audrey despite being raised by the
caring and hard-working Cinderella
Ted is nothing like his mom tad wants
nothing more than to make Audrey happy
so he agrees that the BK's belong in the
Isle ends nowhere else but unlike Audrey
chad has a huge extended family on the
Isle of the Lost
his mother's stepsisters Drizella and
Anastasia have families of their own
this makes Chad step cousins with dizzy
her six sisters and Anthony Tremaine we
wonder Chad will warm up to his extended
family now that the barrier has been
taken down Doug dag is one of the
sweetest are dying kids of all time
which makes him compatible with the
fashion-forward Eevee dove is the son of
dopey from Disney's Snow White and he
was raised to help those in need
the name of Doug's mother has never
mentioned throughout the films but we do
see Toby standing next to a beautiful
woman at Ben's coronation and she's
believed to be Doug's mother despite
coming off as an only child doug has a
handful of brothers
mal the future Queen of auradon has got
one complicated family tree she's a
daughter of Maleficent and Hades who are
some of the most powerful Disney
villains of all time Hades is the
brother of Zeus and Poseidon which makes
mal first cousins with Hercules and
since King Triton is the son of Poseidon
mouths also cousins with Princess Ariel
mal has a half-brother called hati who
is strictly introduced and returned to
the Isle of the Lost a descendents novel
if you're wondering how OMA and now
might be related it's through King
Triton and Ursula Disney executives
originally wanted to make Ursula Ariel's
and but they chose to leave it out of
the script still are slit hands - having
lived in the castle with King Triton
pausing fans to peg them as siblings so
mal could be connected to OMA through
her father's godly roots who is your
favorite dissonance character and why
tell us in the comments hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching the things see you next
time
[Music]